I was going bros my it's beautiful Jam
here we fill what are we gonna do the
name yet we made a game it's alright so
we pull it over
it's alright no it's good it's amazing
it made a game version of the 7 second
challenge which is quite funny cuz Phil
made the 7 second challenge yeah but
then the video that you guys made
playing it has 10 times as many views as
Phil ok so the 7 second challenge you've
seen it with me marks and basically you
have seven seconds person and then
gathers plan you die Wow
so the time-fill versus feeling yeah yes
google ok are you ready yes what three
things would you do if you swapped
bodies with the opposite sex
get make it get funky yeah weird what's
the difference
okay I don't need to explain yeah okay
is that a nail or fact is I was a nail
bit really
all right I can do this
you can do it I believe in you no one
helped me I know the first challenge is
using the app right describe one of the
people near you right now come Maya she
has what I have she's very sexy
she likes pens go team us are you ready
for this one
yes okay Felix put the leg behind your
head oh that was incredibly impressive
but that's a strong nail yeah that's
sammich Matt Wow I mean that sounded
pretty backwards to me was my name
Daniel James Howell good you're always
the worst friend know what you want to
just proud it sounded
design in pretty good name three things
you'd happily blow up with dynamite
sharks in the state well evil people and
the small country yeah they're like an
entire species
yeah well that's I'm sorry Paul Jimmy
didn't like center net southern debt we
could yes I like that because it makes
everything meaningless so so that that
means if you go back so whoever fails is
out yeah oh gosh that's hard okay
so today we're going up in death if you
lose you're out and you'll throw it into
the sea what's yeah feelings potential
ovaries just exploded
[Music]
Wow
mane five animals you wouldn't find in a
zoo the people Russians dead animals
cats dogs pigs aha you would find a
cleanser would you find pigs in the zoo
yeah you find cats as animals yeah say
which body part you would make robotic
and explain why my butt so I can sit
down and it wouldn't hurt yeah this is a
nerve test so get your credit ready to
be destroyed or not okay name five
mythological creatures the Pegasus
unicorn chainsaw everyone loves the
chainsaw man oh it's sugar ethology I
was thinking of Texas Chainsaw mascara
he's a psychopathic Alex's Oh buddy
nothing dad defeated dad it's gonna roll
off the couch okay I'm actually good
okay good
it's concern that forever how'd you feel
about winning oh yeah we made no problem
dad Phil thanks so much for coming on
this comfy couch
check out that or fill in the
description and most of all check out
the second half thank you thank you
it's amazing
this means a lot I need to prep myself
give me psyching yourself up this yeah
[Music]